Bond fans certainly can cherry-pick their
favorites. But there's really only one way
to view these adventures as the work of
one semi-ageless operative — and it's not
in chronological order. You've been watching
James Bond movies all wrong, and here's why.
To start at the character's beginning
means 2006's Casino Royale, the franchise
reboot that served as Daniel Craig's Bond
debut. Based on Fleming's first Bond novel,
the film gives Bond a gritty origin story
in which he earns his "Double-0" status,
drives off with his signature Aston
Martin, and uses his brawn as well
as his wits — like when he flings an empty
handgun right back in an opponent's face.
Most importantly, the film refreshes
the trope of a woman who does him wrong
by having a genuine love story with an unwilling
betrayal. Eva Green's treasury liaison Vesper
Lynd throws real sparks with Craig, revealing a
striking complexity beneath Bond's flinty gaze.
Phoebe Waller-Bridge, the Fleabag star and
co-screenwriter of No Time to Die, told GQ -
"He let us in a bit, which makes the moments
he shuts us out even more arresting. Overall,
he grounded a fantasy character in real emotion,
which is what I think we hadn't realized we'd
missed amongst the action and the bravado."
Quantum of Solace, released in 2008,
picks up where Casino Royale left off,
with Bond discovering that criminal banker
Le Chiffre is part of a larger terrorist
organization called Quantum. He also ferrets
out more about Vesper's past. Unfortunately,
the Writer's Guild strike at the time hampered
a cohesive plot, with Craig admitting to GQ -
"We didn't have a script. So we
concentrated a lot on the stunts."
Craig's third outing, Skyfall, continued
to develop Bond as a character,
particularly his relationship with M.
After a botched mission with new agent Eve,
Bond is presumed dead. But when vengeful
ex-agent Raoul Silva targets M and MI6,
Bond returns as M's protector, taking her to
Skyfall, his childhood home in the Scottish
Highlands. There, viewers see the headstones of
his parents, and their surname confirms that James
Bond is the same character across the franchise,
admittedly one without much of a secret identity.
Bond defeats Silva, but M dies,
throwing off the continuity when Dench
turns up in the Pierce Brosnan years.
As much as the Craig films
serve as Bond's origin story,
2015's Spectre also delves into his
connection to the criminal organization,
a frequent adversary from Fleming's novels. On
the trail of Mr. White, a character from Casino
Royale and Quantum of Solace, Bond learns that
the Quantum organization is a SPECTRE subsidiary.
He also meets White's daughter, psychologist
Madeleine Swann. The two follow SPECTRE's
trail to Morocco, where they wind up prisoners
of a man Bond recognizes as Franz Oberhauser,
son of a foster father from Bond's youth.
Oberhauser reveals that his current name is
Ernst Stavro Blofeld, which rings a bell for
Bond aficionados. As Oberhauser, he'd faked
his death, and now he's in charge of SPECTRE,
which has an MI6 mole with designs
on a global surveillance network.
Of course, Bond foils Blofeld's plan, then
drives off with Swann, leaving espionage behind.
No Time to Die forces him back into
the field as CIA pal Felix Leiter
asks for help in pursuing Safin, an anarchist
and ex-SPECTRE assassin. Meanwhile, Blofeld
stirs up trouble while in custody, and a secret
from Swann's past surfaces. It's safe to assume
that whatever else No Time to Die has in store,
Bond's relationship with Swann won't survive.
Dr. No, released in 1962, officially introduced
moviegoers to Fleming's secret agent,
along with the concept of the "Bond girl" and an
eccentric, power-crazy villain. Sean Connery's
Bond heads to Jamaica to investigate
the slaying of another British agent,
discovering that the death is connected to
recent sabotage of the U.S. space program.
His investigation leads to a private island,
where he encounters Honey Ryder, a gorgeous diver
searching for seashells. The two meet the
island's owner, Dr. Julius No, a SPECTRE
agent and nuclear scientist aiming to take over
a U.S. rocket launch as revenge for both the
Americans and the East not recognizing his genius.
Thanks to Bond, his plans end in a meltdown.
Connery's follow-up, 1963's From Russia with Love,
further explores SPECTRE and its nefarious plans
as Bond goes undercover to meet Tatiana Romanova,
a Russian cipher clerk wanting to defect
with a decoder device. She turns out to be
an unwitting pawn in a SPECTRE assassination
plot against Bond for killing Dr. No.
Bond strangles one SPECTRE assassin and
goes toe-to-toe with another wielding a
poisoned spike in her shoe. Romanova comes to
his defense, proving that love conquers all.
Definitely one of the most memorable Bond
films, Goldfinger finds Bond looking into
Auric Goldfinger, a gold magnate who smuggles
the stuff out of England through the bodywork
of his Rolls-Royce. But Goldfinger has a grander
scheme in mind: Destroying the gold reserve in
Fort Knox with an atomic bomb, rendering
it useless and thus cementing his wealth.
To enter Fort Knox, Goldfinger enlists
an elite squad of female pilots to spray
nerve gas, which will kill thousands. Bond
wins over the improbably named squadron
leader Pussy Galore before stopping the
bomb with a precise 007 seconds to spare.
Connery told The New York Times at the time -
"It sort of demonstrates what I believe
is a subtler, more discriminating Bond
than you have seen in the earlier films.
[…] I guess I'm trying to make James Bond
grow up a little — in the same way that
I'm growing up myself. Not too much,
though. Definitely not too much. That
would spoil the fun for both of us."
Thunderball, released in 1965, sends
Bond to the Bahamas to recover two
nuclear warheads that Emilio Largo, second
in command at SPECTRE, hijacks for ransom.
Swiping them involved brainwashing a pilot and
sending him for plastic surgery, something Bond
discovers while visiting a health spa for some
R&R under M's orders. Eventually, Bond pieces
together that the brainwashed pilot, whom SPECTRE
kills, is the brother of Domino, Largo's mistress.
You Only Live Twice, released in 1967, showed
Connery's Bond at last meeting SPECTRE leader
Ernst Stavro Blofeld. After an attempt on
Bond's life, complete with a burial at sea,
Bond re-emerges and joins forces with Tiger
Tanaka of Japanese Intelligence. Tanaka suggests
that Bond marry to pose as a local fisherman so he
can investigate under cover. The bride is another
agent, Kissy Suzuki, who is all business. The two
uncover a secret SPECTRE base within a volcano,
where Blofeld hoped to deceive the Soviets
and Americans into starting World War III.
With those plans thwarted, Kissy and Bond decide
to enjoy their honeymoon until MI6 interrupts.
Australian actor George Lazenby stepped
into Bond's shoes in 1969's On Her Majesty's
Secret Service. After he rescues the
suicidal Contessa Tracy di Vicenzo
from drowning in the opening moments, she
drives away, leaving Bond dumbstruck — and
spurring theories of "James Bond" being a
codename with a cheeky aside to the camera.
"This never happened to the other fellow."
The espionage plot is a little kooky
this time around, with Blofeld running
an allergy clinic in the Swiss Alps that's
really a way to brainwash attendees into
distributing biological warfare. But that's
secondary to Bond's relationship with Tracy,
the spirited but troubled daughter of a mob
boss. Tracy, a skilled skier as well as driver,
gamely helps Bond throughout the movie,
and the two marry toward the film's end.
Then Blofeld and an assassin pepper their
car with bullets after the ceremony,
killing Tracy and leaving Bond poignantly
holding her behind the shattered windshield.
Connery returned as Bond in 1971's Diamonds
Are Forever, which begins with him tracking
down Blofeld to an underground lair where the
SPECTRE leader prepares for plastic surgery.
Bond ties Blofeld to an operating table
and plunges it into a steaming mud lake,
presumably avenging Tracy's death, although his
late wife isn't mentioned elsewhere in the film.
"Welcome to Hell Blofeld."
As Bond investigates who is stealing
huge quantities of diamonds,
he learns that the Blofeld in the lair was
actually a double for the real Blofeld,
currently hanging out in Las Vegas under
the guise of multimillionaire Willard Whyte.
With the help of conniving
jewel smuggler Tiffany Case,
Bond figures out that the diamonds are
powering a space satellite and laser
aimed at nuclear installations around
the world. They stop the destruction,
of course, although Tiffany wonders if there's
any way to get those sparklers back to Earth.
Roger Moore took over as 007 with 1973's
Live and Let Die. Moore definitely brought
a lighter touch to Bond, but this film's
blaxploitation influences haven't aged well.
"Well you just keep on the tail of that
jukebox and there's an extra 20 in it for you."
"Hey man, for 20 bucks, I'll take
you to a Ku Klux Klan cookout."
The plot has Bond checking out a heroin operation
controlled by a Caribbean dictator and a gangster,
both of whom are actually the same person in
disguise. There's a lengthy motorboat chase,
a wince-inducing Southern sheriff, alligators,
voodoo, and some duplicitous
consent with the film's women,
blaxploitation actress Gloria Hendry playing
a field agent, and the tarot reader Solitaire.
Moore's next Bond film, 1974's The Man with the
Golden Gun, finds him the target of Francisco
Scaramanga, the world's most expensive assassin,
who kills with a single shot from a specialized
weapon. Bond also delves into the work of a
scientist wanting to harness the sun's power
to solve the energy crisis. When M calls him off
that mission for his safety, Bond ignores him,
learning that Scaramanga is after not just Bond
as a trophy but the solar technology as well.
With SPECTRE seemingly gone, the Bond films
of the 1970s into the 1990s focused more on
Cold War antagonists. The Spy Who Loved Me,
from 1977, does that with the cheekiness and
excess of the Moore era, but
for some reason, it all works.
When British and Soviet nuclear submarines
vanish, Bond follows a lead to Cairo,
where he runs across Russian Major Anya
Amasova working the case from the Soviet end.
The two form a tenuous alliance to defeat
wealthy shipping entrepreneur Karl Stromberg,
who wants the submarines to launch armageddon so
he can create a new civilization beneath the sea.
Stromberg likes sharks that devour enemies
and has a metal-toothed henchman named
Jaws. For all its flash, the film also has a
notable callback to Bond's late wife, Tracy.
"Many lady friends, but married
only once. Wife killed -"
"All right you've made your point."
Blame the success of Star Wars for launching
Bond into space with 1979's Moonraker,
a film that copies the basic plot of The Spy
Who Loved Me — with that film's henchman,
Jaws, now working for a different megalomaniac
who wants to kill people and start over fresh.
This time, Hugo Drax, a supplier of
space shuttles to the US government,
makes off with a shuttle to transport a
new "master race" to his space station.
It's not enough to leave Earth behind,
though. Drax also has concocted a lethal
toxin to kill the not-so-worthy
humans trapped on the planet.
The film includes a wild chase through Venice
where a gondola becomes a hovercraft and a full-on
laser battle in space. Bond also gets a hand
from one of the smarter women of the Moore era,
an astronaut and CIA agent with the
eye-rolling name of Holly Goodhead.
At least she can pilot a shuttle.
Bond went more down to earth for 1981's For Your
Eyes Only. The agent searched the Mediterranean
for a missing British ship equipped with a weapons
encryption device, meeting Melina Havelock,
a crossbow-wielding woman whose parents worked
with the British government. Her quest for revenge
against whoever killed them dovetails with a
secret KGB agent, Kristatos, and a Greek smuggler.
The film includes realistic action
scenes both underwater and during a
mountain-climbing climax. But first, it closes
the book on SPECTRE. In the opening moments,
as Bond visits the grave of his late wife Tracy,
a helicopter arrives to whisk him back to MI6.
Once in the air, a surge of electricity
through the headset kills the pilot,
and Blofeld, now using a wheelchair, takes
control of the craft from the ground.
The agent manages to rip out cables
connecting Blofeld's remote control,
then flies after his one time nemesis, scooping
up the wheelchair on one of the chopper's
skids and dropping him down a smokestack.
For Moore's final two Bond outings,
the agent again dealt with Cold War
machinations. In 1983's Octopussy, Bond becomes
involved with a jewelry smuggler and circus
owner who gives the film its title. She's in
league with exiled Afghan prince Kamal Khan,
who's actually using her circus operation to stage
a nuclear accident with a rogue Soviet general.
There are acrobatic thieves, a hunt in India
that's an homage to the short story "The
Most Dangerous Game," and disguises for Bond
that include an ape costume and a clown suit.
Moore hung up his Walther PPK after 1985's
A View to a Kill, which pitted Bond against
industrialist Max Zorin, a psychopath
thanks to failed Soviet steroid experiments.
Zorin has a striking henchwoman named May Day,
and designs on destroying Silicon Valley through
an earthquake so he can control the microchip
market. Naturally, a San Francisco geologist
helps Bond disrupt Zorin's plans, resulting in
a showdown atop the landmark Golden Gate Bridge.
Royal Shakespeare Company actor Timothy
Dalton starred as Bond in 1987's The Living
Daylights. As The Guardian noted, his more
"nuanced and complex interpretation" hewed
closer to Fleming's novels but perplexed
fans accustomed to the quippy Moore years.
Dalton is introduced during a training exercise
at the Rock of Gibraltar, where an assassin picks
off several agents until the film reveals the
new 007. Defecting KGB General Georgi Koskov
says his former superior has revived a spy
assassination program, but Bond later learns that
Koskov is in league with an American arms dealer
and wants the man dead for business reasons.
Because of the AIDS epidemic, Bond
is a one-woman man this time around,
forging a romance with Kara Milovy, a
cellist who had been Koskov's girlfriend.
Dalton's follow-up, 1989's License to Kill,
finds Bond on a cold-blooded personal crusade
against a drug dealer whose men leave
Felix Leiter for dead and kill his bride,
Della. Before her death, Della wonders why their
friend James hasn't found a steady sweetheart,
and Felix briefly explains
that he was once married.
Because of legal issues, Bond didn't return to
theaters until 1995's GoldenEye, which starred
Pierce Brosnan after Dalton resigned. The film
starts about a decade before the present day,
with Bond on a job with fellow "00" agent and
friend Alec Trevelyan, who seemingly dies.
Of course, events in Bond's life
are rarely what they appear,
and Bond later learns that Alec is
alive and leading a crime syndicate.
He seeks a satellite-based electromagnetic
pulse weapon known as GoldenEye.
The filmmakers attempted to update Bond for
modern audiences by giving him
a female M who criticizes him:
"I think you're a sexist, misogynist
dinosaur. A relic of the Cold War."
But some Bond things never change.
They also gave Alec a leggy accomplice,
Xenia Onatopp, who likes to
crush victims between her thighs.
Bond gets some assistance from a CIA contact
who disconcertingly calls Bond Jimbo,
as well as Natalya, a Russian computer programmer
who flirts with getting Bond to settle down.
Brosnan's second outing, 1997's Tomorrow
Never Dies, explores more of Bond's past
by introducing a former girlfriend, Paris,
now married to Elliot Carver, a tabloid
media mogul. Carver draws MI6's attention after
a spurious signal from one of his company's
communication satellites occurs at the same
time a British warship sinks in Chinese waters.
Paris helps Bond infiltrate her husband's
headquarters for old times' sake,
for which Carver has her killed.
Carver has a more unusual scheme for a Bond
villain: He wants to secure exclusive broadcasting
rights in China in exchange for starting
a war between the British and the Chinese.
Fortunately, Bond finds an ally in Wai Lin,
a Chinese agent who can handle herself.
1999's The World Is Not Enough packed
an impressive twist. At M's request,
Bond retrieves money from a Swiss banker
for British oil tycoon Sir Robert King,
a particular sum that turns out
to be treated with an explosive.
Bond deduces that someone wanted to send
a message by killing King through the cash
because King's daughter Elektra had recently
been ransomed for the same amount of money.
Although he presumes that the terrorist
who kidnapped Elektra is responsible,
King's killer turns out to be Elektra herself.
She's developed feelings for her kidnapper,
and the two want to detonate a nuclear
explosion in Istanbul, leaving the King
pipeline the only viable route for extracting
petroleum from that region. Along to diffuse
the situation is a nuclear physicist with the
eye-roll inducing name of Dr. Christmas Jones.
Brosnan's tenure as Bond finished
with 2002's Die Another Day.
Released the same year as the 40th anniversary of
Dr. No, the film pays homage in some ways to other
previous Bond films and Fleming's novels. One such
nod? Having Bond pick up the book A Field Guide
to Birds of the West Indies, whose author James
Bond inspired the name of Fleming's famous spy.
The plot mirrors some elements of previous
entries with an adversary whom Bond thought
was dead assuming a new identity to build a
space laser out of diamonds. NSA agent Jinx
Johnson teams up with Bond in a story that becomes
more fantastical than some fans liked. Bond surfs
through an iceberg tsunami, there's an ice palace,
and the Aston Martin Vanquish becomes invisible.
Although he felt shocked
over being replaced at first,
Brosnan in 2020 said he has, quote, "no regret"
over his 007 days, telling The Guardian -
"Bond is the gift that keeps giving and
has allowed me to have a wonderful career.
Once you're branded as a
Bond, it's with you forever."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
iconic film franchises are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.